I don't go home for the holidays and
that surprises a lot of people and I
don't do it because I don't like what
going back home does for me and that's
not just family that's friends
environments places I go to people I
speak with anything for me I left home
because I wanted to be a different
person I wanted to change my environment
and I wanted to start clean and move in
the direction of the person that I
wanted to be I think the main reason
that I want to make this video is
because there's probably a younger
version of me out there that is
terrified of the idea of not listening
to their parents and going home for the
holidays listen if you love your family
and it's like the highlight of year then
[__] go if I'm talking to Young mosy
the biggest fear that I had was what
people would think about me if I didn't
go out with them when I was back home
because it's like well I'm back home for
a week they're like yo you're back home
let's whatever and I would feel
obligated because I'm back home and I'm
only back home a couple times a year but
the reason that I haven't been in touch
with that person when I'm not back home
is because they try and meet me in my
past and treat me in a way that I used
to accept them treating me as I've grown
in their word changed I no longer accept
the type of behavior and it's not just
the things they say it's how they say it
and a lot of times like it's not super
direct a lot of times it's indirect
especially if it's people who like you
this is why it's so tough when you have
a cousin or an uncle who says oh you
know how you are and they say like that
cuz they want you to be like oh yeah I
know how I am but the thing is is that
when you do that you basically agree you
accept their label of who you are which
is often the person that you used to be
that you literally left there to try and
change this was super tough for me
because you know I have lots of
traditions and hey come on like aunt
whatever is going to make pumpkin pie
again oh you know so so is bringing her
meatloaf or whatever it is and so you
can't miss it but the thing is is you
absolutely [__] can you can
absolutely miss it I made a video about
this four or five years ago and it was
one of my top videos that I made and I
thought it was worth a refresh and one
of the things I said in the video was I
have become increasingly intolerant of
people treating me in a way that I don't
accept and I said you know maybe in the
future 5 years from now I'll look back
on this video and think hey maybe I was
a little too harsh maybe I was a little
too extreme and the reality is the exact
opposite I'm even less tolerant now than
I was then so if you're sitting on the
couch right and someone says hey get
over
here if they said something like that to
me in that
tone I would say don't talk to me that
way I'm not your dog like what do you
need they like uh just get over here and
i' be like no you're just repeating the
same thing and then it gets to this
really awkward point in those awkward
moments is when you reframe and you
retach someone to treat you if you think
it's uncomfortable for you it's even
more uncomfortable for them one because
they're not used to it and no one does
this it's also why most people are
mediocre and never get out of the Doom
Loops they have from back home and they
fall right back into the old behaviors
that they were trying to get away from
when you're teaching that person of how
you how you want to be treated you're
saying you can do whatever you want I
have no control over how you choose to
speak to me but I do have control over
what I will choose to do in response and
so if you would like me to get up and
help you with with this thing simply ask
me hey Alex are you busy right now and I
might say yes or no if I'm not you might
say would you mind helping me with these
things and I might say of course happy
to help but if you say get over here I'm
never going to respond to that and you
repeating it louder in no way makes
makes it more likely it I'll respond a
lot of times it's these little things
like this it's these micro exchanges
because it's rare that someone's like
you are not happy Alex they don't really
do that not often sometimes they do like
I mean I'll give you a couple examples
like ah you have such a short temper
right I'll get that one when I go back
home anybody who knows me now probably
would not describe me that way and
here's a key Point what most people want
to say even if they have the balls to to
step up and this is and kudos for even
stepping up if you say hey you know what
please don't say that I'm really working
on it that's a great half step in the
direction but believe it or not it
actually makes no progress here's why if
you say I'm working on it you're still
accepting their frame that you are that
way if you want to be a different person
then you need to behave a different way
which means that if you want to step
into that identity of the person who
doesn't struggle with drinking or
doesn't struggle with their temper then
imagine what that person would say in
response so if you don't struggle with
drinking and you have no temper and
someone says hey Alex you know how you
have a temper I would say no I don't I
don't know yeah you do I mean you've
always had a temper like I might have in
the past I don't now please don't speak
to me that way it doesn't help me unless
you prefer that I be angry whoa you're
getting angry no I'm stating facts I'm
asking a question would you prefer that
I be angry no well then don't tell me
that I am are you here to help me or are
you here to get me to behave the way you
want me to it's very tough for people to
see people change because often times
when we change in our world grow we
remind them of the changes they've been
incapable of making we remind them of
their own deficiencies of their own
failures of the Comfort zones that they
had been unwilling to step out of that
we were willing to take the risk for to
figure out whether your family and the
people that you're going home to are
conducive to your goals what behaviors
do I need to do to achieve the goals I
want and do these people support those
behaviors or do they detract from those
behaviors that's it if when you get in
that environment you are less likely to
do the behaviors that you say you're
committing to so that you can be the
person you want to be and achieve the
things you want to achieve then that
would be a detractor if they are helping
you and they are supporting you and they
are they're clearing the way and they're
giving you attention back then that's an
amazing family and they are supporting
you in your goals and this is the
double-edged sword this is the Paradox
is that the loving caring family that
would say hey I respect that you're
trying to make this change go do what's
right for you so you can become that
person that's probably the family you'd
want to go home to right and that's the
Paradox of this if the family and the
people around you the people that you
went back home in high school and to
have your your your high school parties
with or whatever actually behave that
way they wouldn't be there they'd be
somewhere else right they would have
moved on they would have grown
themselves and so that's the tough part
about it if you are young mosy and you
don't have a lot waiting for you back
home in terms of what you're looking
forward to I just want to give you one
outside person's permission if you need
that to not go home you can miss a
holiday and if you need language around
that you just just say I'm not saying
this is forever I'm just saying this is
for now that's it easy language and if
they throw a tantrum that is on them
they may miss you and the thing is is
that there are elements that you may
miss too the question is just whether
it's worth the tradeoff here's an easy
way to think about this when you go home
there are positives there are some
things that are positive there are also
things that are
negative they exist separately it's the
reason that people get into abusive
relationships they have lots of positive
and they also have lots of negative and
so when they break up with the quote
abusive person or the person that they
have some chemically you know crazy
Dynamic with they feel like they miss
the person because reward does not
decrease over time but your reminder of
punishment does so let me give you a
tactical example on this have you ever
finished a night of drinking and the
next morning you say I'm never going to
drink again probably but then what do
you do the next weekend you drink why
because punishment decreases in its
Effectiveness over time you quickly
forget and then you do it again reward
is actually different than that which is
why when you think about a relationship
10 years in the past you think about all
the sweet memories because all of the
punishment associated with the
relationship disappears but then you get
back in the relationship and you're like
holy cow I forgot all all this crap and
so what happens is we spend a long time
away from our families and we remember
all the good we forget all the bad but
then we get back home we're reminded of
all the negative things and why we left
to begin with I try to actively cue
myself and remind myself of the many
reasons that I chose to leave center
point of that is because I didn't think
it would help me become the person I
wanted to become especially this is for
young mosy if you are if you're in a
season right now of trying to become a
new man or a new woman and you're trying
to flex your muscles of being on time of
being consistent of of maybe not
drinking too much of of staying in the
Rhythm that you're in right you've got
you've got this little work grind that's
going you've had you've had a good
streak you're like being productive
you're making
progress don't break it it's not worth
the trade-off how does you drinking Aunt
son so's eggnog and having a couple of
pictures and having some weird comments
from your uncle that you don't talk to
that much and getting some political
argument that doesn't matter anyways how
does that make you better the only
reason you go back is because you're
afraid of what people will say imagine
play it out you've got the whole family
there and not you version a they just
forget that you're not there and they
keep living their lives in which case
Kudos it's fine on the other hand the
entirety of the room [__] talks you the
whole time you're there are you really
sad you're missing it you choosing not
to go has no downside in terms of if
they have a negative experience or you
have negative experiences being there
and if they treat you negatively and so
we have all these positive memories
because it's impossible to live an
entire life without positive memories
right you just also have negative ones
and the question is is the upside worth
the downside and so for me especially as
I was coming up through this I noticed
that I would get tons of anxiety going
into the holidays I would dread certain
occasions I would dread certain
Traditions that would happen and I hated
all of it and one day I was like why am
I putting up with this [__] like there's
no rule that says I have to go back and
then I gave myself permission to not go
back you know what happened I kept
living and so did they the people from
high school they just moved on they
found other people to find Drinking
Buddies with and if they're like oh
Heros thinks he's better than us okay
different for sure if you want to be
exceptional and I will say this again
then it means you will be an exception
the majority of people will not behave
the way you are they will say why are
you acting so weird why are you behaving
this way this isn't normal what's going
on they're going to ask you these
questions because they want you to get
back in line but back in line leads down
the road and you know where that road
ends and you you know that's not where
you want to be that's for anybody who
doesn't want to go home now if you do
have elements of people who you do love
there and you have elements of people
you don't like there then I would say
just avoid the people that you don't
want to be with and that means that you
can just simply not respond to their
text when they ask you to hang out I
know crazy you can also just not put
yourself in like if someone say hey sit
next to me and you're like ah I don't
want to crazy you just tell them the
truth I don't want to this is the ab
absolute litus t test for navigating
these controversial conversations
elegantly is that you simply tell the
truth and it's because there's so many
perceived social obligations around
holidays what's expected of you what
you're supposed to do what you're
supposed to pay for what you're supposed
to help set up what about the tree what
about the presents what are you going to
do right if you still feel obligated you
can send money for presents and say
Here's money for everyone the truth is
what you would say to your real friends
or to the few people that you care about
about the situation so I don't want to
go to my aunt's house it's like so and
so drinks too much and so and so is
always inappropriate and I always get in
political arguments I just don't want to
deal with it you say that to them you
always get in political arguments you
always get too drunk you're always
inappropriate I just don't want to deal
with it you just say that rather than
making up some BS answer because they're
going to overcome your BS because it's
BS and so they will have the upper hand
because they are telling the truth and
you are not you state the facts I don't
want to come I'm doing really well or
hey I will come on the condition that
I'm not going to talk to so and so and I
want to make sure that you as the host
are okay with that and I will have a
conversation with them up front letting
them know that I'm not interested in
talking to them you say hey Uncle John
there's 38 people here at our holiday
get together talk to any of the other 37
but me that's it and if you need to make
Grandma you're welcome to just don't
include me in it please also one of the
things that I think is underrated is is
Leisure Time just because you are home
and you don't have some scheduled
doesn't mean everyone has free access to
your time if you want to stay in and
watch a movie because you're on holiday
break and it's one of the few times that
you just do that even if it's just you
and not even with your family then if
someone says hey let's go out and you
say no I'm good and they say what like
what are you busy tonight or what do you
have plans or if they start with hdf
plans and you say no and they say you
want to go out you can also right after
they say that say no because rest is
productive if it Nets you a gain in how
much you can do if you rest well during
the holidays and you're more productive
after the holidays that's a good thing
if you feel like you have to recover
from your holidays then you don't even
get the main benefit of holidays if we
think about how we curate our
environment the wealthier the people
that I meet the more contained and
pristine their environments are they
don't allow people who are detracting
from the people they want to be and the
behaviors they want to do in and so
think about Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos or
Steve Jobs think about the teams of
people that they have around them do you
think you can be an idiot and be in Elon
musk's presence do you think you can be
a drunkard and be in bezos's presence do
you think you can be like an idiot and
passive aggressive and Mak SN remarks in
in in Steve Jobs presence no why because
they're intolerant of that they have a
higher standard and so if you remember
the first girlfriend or first boyfriend
you ever had versus what your standards
are today your standards rise as you
grow as you become better so too do your
expectations or rather should your
expectations become of others that you
surround yourself with and so if you're
spending all this time working on the
person and the character that you're
trying to build and then you just dilute
it with crap around you it's very tough
to get back to that which is why you
feel like you have to take one or two
weeks to shed the bad behaviors and the
bad habits that you picked right back up
when you went back home and so for me
it's like I would rather not have you
know a week or two of of bad bad lack of
rest where everyone feels that they're
entitled to my time entitled to my
energy going into another week or two
afterwards where I have to recover from
this vacation it's like I just I ate up
three four weeks of my year it's 8% of
my year my whole year because of a
social expectation to me that's
ridiculous and so I don't subscribe I
opt out we create our reality we create
the Rules of Engagement for other people
to interact with us we teach and
reinforce others for the way that they
treat us if we don't like the way
someone treats us we don't like the way
someone talks to us it's our
responsibility to set it straight and if
they do not adhere to the agreements
that you have set then you don't need to
play anymore and their loss is your
company and then you keep living in your
life I think this is epic tetus but he
says like how do you get angry at a rock
you can call a rock names you can shout
at it you can stop your feet but the
rock just stays a rock and so if they
get all upset just be the rock be like I
understand got it not going to change my
behavior but I understand having these
hard conversations gives us the space to
be the people that we want to be on the
terms that we set rather than the ones
that are thrust Upon Us by social
expectations and cultural norms that
were created for people who are not
trying to achieve the goals that we are
I'm only sharing this because some of
you who are listening to this are
actually going to achieve big [__] and
it's going to feel really lonely for a
lot of that time and it's because you're
going to feel like the odd man out and
you're going to feel like what you're
doing is contrary to what everyone else
is doing the people who are back there
are going to you know call you names
behind your back they're going to say
you think you're better than them
they're going to say that you forgot
where you came from and you just develop
a thicker skin because you realize that
they say those things and yet you still
continue and yet you keep living and you
keep getting closer to your goals and
then the thing is is goal after goal
starts falling down and you get more and
more evidence that this path is the path
you should be on and you'll feel more
and more confident to the point where in
the future you you just have no issue
with that you'll have zero tolerance
someone texts you just block them like I
don't care I don't need it I just don't
need it and so I am significantly less
tolerant than I was in my first video
four or five years ago and I was pretty
intolerant then maybe 5 years from now
I'll uh I'll recant all of this stuff
but maybe 5 years from now I'll say the
same thing that I do now and maybe I'll
be even less tolerant I'm making this
for young mosy who needs to hear that
and if you have an amazing family that's
awesome go back enjoy the holidays keep
living you but this is just for the
people who aren't stoked about going
back for the holidays and are not sure
what to do